un parfum d'enfance avec les aventures
du petit nicolas de goscinny et sempé ce
mois ci est toujours sous la plume des
mêmes auteurs et dessinateurs sorte 80
histoires inédites comme l'on dit de 7 à
77 ans marie-hélène bonne au chant
l'uimm la chine ou pour le réveillon g
et vous il y aura mais ma tante de voter
et ton temps et gêne chez nous m'a dit
elle c'est il y aura du boudin blanc et
de la dinde alpes est le gros qui mange
tout le temps l'un des piliers de la
chouette bande de copains comme dit
nicolas l'avis de quelques écoliers à
peine différents de ceux d'aujourd'hui
qui s'y colle avec ses parents il est
comme vous à vos parents mais un petit
peu plus respectueux quand même son
brutus folie en fait que de nos jours on
dirait un gros plein grand mot anne
goscinny la fille de l'auteur a voulu
avec sempé faire découvrir ou
redécouvrir cet univers tantôt ya pas de
vulgarité et c'est une espèce de vie
idéal c'est un conte
avec des personnages entre guillemets
réel et irréel force elle en 1955 deux
humoristes de génie le dessinateur santé
et le scénariste goscinny créé cette
drôle d'équipée de gama tempête xynthia
duo jamais égalée alors qu'elle ne
reviendrait pas à 12
441 c'est l'histoire tout paru dans sud
ouest ou pilotes ont été publiés en cinq
volumes mais il en restait on y retrouve
au hasard clotaire le mauvais élève
chaque fois qu'il est interrogé les
privés de récréation quand il a même
sans livret scolaire il est privé de
télévision il est privé de cinéma et
quand les directeurs legrand du niveau
parents se prive de tout pour donner une
éducation
nostalgie pour cent p qui se replonge 45
ans en arrière lui qui n'a jamais plus
redessiné le petit nicolas croque son
ami pour anne goscinny pour le livre les
dessins de presse de l'époque ont été
reproduits les originaux ont disparu ils
ont été garés dans des imprimeries ou
volé ce terreau enfin comme ça se
passait dans les journaux à l'époque et
donc je ne me voyais pas en train de les
refaire ce petit bonhomme dessiner des
centaines de fois revient dans 80
aventure inédite